i want to show you the story from
rolling stone ian i got bad news for you
crosby stills nash and young reunite
who's removing their music from spotify
no
we support neil and we agree with him
that there is dangerous disinformation
being aired on spotify's joe rogan
podcast
what information
what what what what what did joe say
what disinformation you don't even watch
the show none of these people do
to go off what you were just saying ian
we need to stop stop pretending that
these people are being serious
they have no idea what they're talking
about they have no idea why they're even
mad all they know is someone on the tv
said joe rogan ben they went uh i'm down
for some free press yeah and that's it
well i mean to be fair tim i think that
their uh target audience is most at risk
for covid
yeah dude it's so good seeing those guys
together that's true and and you know
what um
these are this is the demographic that
watches cnn exactly so they see all the
lies they walk right into it look man
i'm gonna listen to it on amazon so i
gotta say ding dong
joe came out he did not apologize for
his guests he said they were
credentialed he said i'm gonna have
these conversations but he said this is
really funny he was like i'll try to
balance it out and make sure we have you
know a more established establishment
voice or something like that effect uh
the following show so if they do have
robert malone they'll have someone else
on and it's just like
joe
you're saying that
the one time
out of you know 100 guests you have one
critical opinion you're going to add in
another one of the 99
mainstream majority opinions everyone's
already heard like you know joe pointed
out he had sanjay gupta and mike
osterholm on his show and then he had
peter mccall and dr malone it's like so
you split it up pretty well
but they're not satisfied with that
so when he you know gives you makes some
concessions and spotify says okay
they wanted a misinformation policy
we'll do it it doesn't matter
spotify came out and said okay okay
we'll do your misinformation policy and
now crosby stills and nash join in and
getting their music
they're not going to stop because they
don't know what they're talking about
they are not talking to you spotify
these these these activists are not
saying spotify we have a demand they're
saying hey guys i'm yelling at spotify
right now that's what they're doing
they're not communicating with any of
these people they don't know why they're
mad they don't know why it matters all
they know is their virtue signaling to
activists they want to spend money on
their music and give them press because
they're has beens and then what ends up
happening is you get 30 people on
twitter who never buy your product and
then the company goes 30 people on
twitter are complaining about our
product better pull it they were never
going to buy your product in the first
place so it's just frustrating when
people keep giving in to obvious
bs and they don't stop when will people
learn
when will anyone learn that when they
come out and say we demand you do this
if you go okay i'll do it ah now we
demand you do this then this uh next we
want these things we have this the list
of demands it's never going to end until
you say shut your mouth you're deleted
if as soon as as soon as i said pull my
music spotify went you got it by delete
and then crosby stills and nash comes
out and says we're going to reunite say
have a nice day you're old anyway bye
just tell them to shove off
you know look i i i get it spotify is
going to lose money
they lost share their shares went down
because of the controversy
many of these lefty you know people will
pull off the platform they knew that was
going to happen when they signed joe
rogan in the first place so make no
concessions well yeah also i mean i have
a hard time believing that before
signing any kind of contract with
spotify joe rogan didn't consider this
possibility and ensure that he would not
be removed from his platform because
some know nothing celebrity said he
should be
i think that would be that would be very
nice if there's anything i really mean
it i could i would be very surprised if
there was anything that spotify could do
well to me this just looks like a bunch
of old or out of touch artists who are
like oh here's my chance to get two
minutes of fame because somebody
somebody said india ari took her music
off spotify and mary trump i have no
idea mary took her podcast
who knew
for young people who want to you know
try to get a spotify account upload some
of their music there's more opportunity
that's right
you're competing for less audience
self-regulation for more audiences
about crosby stills nash is again
exposing the hypocrisy of the left these
were the counter culture right back in
the 60s
um the baby boomers the anti-war you
know freedom etc and now they're just
aged you know grumpy
old men who are trying to you know cut
down the young upstart
um it just once again the left is just
full of hypocrisy
these are the guys who you know 50 years
ago were leading
you know music's attempts to you know in
the 60s they were
they were powerful in terms of their
messaging and now here they are trying
to didn't know i mean who would have
seen this coming but it just exposes
what the left is didn't neil young have
a free speech tour yeah i think he did
yeah i watched him talking about covet a
couple days ago and he was like we we
can beat this thing his voice is way
higher than you think when you listen to
him talk
we can beat it i know we can we can do
it and it's like what is he talking
about beat this thing you don't talk
about like the common the rhino virus
like we're going to beat this thing it
just is there they don't even know what
they're talking about i mean they
couldn't even put two sentences together
to make sense of anything but this they
got their headlines and that's all they
care about you just gotta stop letting
like
for whatever reason
people seem to think that the kid
throwing a temper tantrum on the on the
playground demanding that you give him
the basketball is going to stop having
temper tantrums when you when you give
him what he wants it's like dude when
the baby starts crying and screaming
like the toddler comes in screaming i
want ice cream you got to be like you
can't have ice cream for breakfast and
they'll scream and they'll cry and then
just be like it's that's not doing
anything for you what if they'll tell
you
eight hours later
of misinformation like nope sorry no ice
cream i used to enjoy four years old
when did you learn my parents i was
lucky that my parents would punish kids
like that and they just isolate them and
make them suffer and cry through the
whole thing until they're done crying
but like what if the kid keeps crying
and keeps crying and keeps crying they
used to eat they can't yeah well they
eventually
they need ice cream as fuel keep trying
you know what happens when a kid is
crying i'll tell you this when a kid is
when a toddler is crying a young kid you
know
saying i want something
and you say well you can't have it and
they keep crying and you walk away you
know what they do as soon as you walk
away stop they stop crying and look
around to figure out where you went why
you weren't giving them attention
because crying doesn't work they figure
out crying doesn't work and they'll stop
they'll try something else
so you can't when when the baby starts
screaming and crying you cannot give the
baby what they want you gotta have to be
a responsible adult and say no
no
no crosby
stop it which is
exactly exactly i understand why you're
sad which is
literally exactly going back to our
earlier story why the truckers need to
stay the course and why we cannot buy
their bs about these people being not
caesar white supremacists or whatever
because that is their temper tantrum
exactly ignore these whiny babies yeah
they're like i haven't slept in five
days and it's like well i can't cross
the border anymore so deal with it yeah
well and here's the thing so if you are
one of these truckers protesting you're
actually giving them a good thing in the
same way that a parent who ignores their
child's temper tantrum is giving them a
good thing because these left wingers
who are slandering you and making
ridiculous accusations about you
as soon as they start to realize that
those really aren't going to work
some of them some small minority maybe
even many of them are going to actually
try to pursue real strategy for
affecting the change they want to see in
the world and i think it's going to make
them more responsible adults and it will
actually reorient their goals away from
leftism so you're helping them
i just want to say i i don't want to
become
i don't seem overly pessimistic on this
because i'm frustrated with these
weirdos let me see if i can uh pull up
joe rogan real quick on instagram
because i want to show you guys
something that's a total white pill
is it just joe rogan on instagram is it
gonna work yeah let's see if it works
all right so where's that post he made
all right we got this post from him so
one of the most important things about
joe rogan's statement on spotify is that
aside from people like you know tulsi
gabbard and tim dillon who are very
obviously fans and friends of his if you
scroll down through joe rogan's post
all of these people
tons of people tons of verified
instagram users are all like joe we love
you you're the best we're on your side
i was looking i was reading an article
and it was like here's a list of
celebrities who came out in defense of
joe rogan on his instagram post saying
awesome things about him and it's like
crosby stills and crabby stills and nash
joining neil young
yo you guys are on the wrong side of
history as the left likes to say joe
rogan's got mainstream look at jewel
you guys know jewel what was that she's
a beautiful voice yeah you're doing a
great job on his show and it was so good
yeah she's good yeah a couple hours it's
not like she's the biggest celebrity in
the world right now but you've got look
at all right now you have high hopes
look at all of these verified users some
obviously we know christina
who's that christina p that's tom
segura's wife well there you go she's
awesome all of the there's a whole bunch
of mainstream
celebrities jamie kennedy ufc fighters
who are like joe's awesome joe is
winning this one even when he comes in
and and can see you know uh uh seed some
ground there i'm not a big fan of it but
the point is as much as it's annoying to
see look you got kelly slater
surfer
they're just they're not they're not on
the side of these crackpots we are
winning free speech is winning right the
the right to free inquiry freedom of
association it's all winning and as
michael malus said when cnn took on joe
rogan their president and the host of
the biggest show got ousted so boom
yeah
victory yeah how wonderful
it feels to wrestle with that i i think
you know uh i saw a po i saw a news
story and it was talking about all of
the celebrities cheering on joe rogan
and i'm like that's the message people
need to hear that with all the stuff
going down and all of these media
outlets being like oh joe did this and
joe did that and these celebrities are
angry you gotta see the bigger picture
what are high profile and regular people
actually saying
they don't believe in the cancel culture
they don't care for it they're fans they
love his show he's got 7.6 million views
on his post he's winning yeah kevin
james kevin james oh really
yeah kevin james and how many new
subscribers how many people have never
heard of him before
uh before this kerfuffle yes exactly i
mean usually this stuff always backfires
too which the left never figures out so
it's like pick your fighter this guy who
you know you have people like grandma
wait who's this joe roll all right i'm
gonna sign up subscribe to him yeah um
oh crosby's still the nash wait what
have they done for the past 50 years or
something so it always backfires so he's
picking up new uh attention he's picking
up support he's picking up new viewers
and it it's just completely backfiring
on them once again
oh no you go i was just going to say i i
can't help feeling that joe rogan is
right now the voice of populism which is
highly encouraging because to see all
these celebrities being on board with
him and also to see all the normal
people who completely agree with him
very encouraging i do think that we are
waiting on this one i just want to pull
up this one more post to make sure
everybody knows oh
from the yeah from the associated press
no evidence video color was manipulated
in cnn news segment september 10th and
then this post showing cnn's version of
the video with joe rogan makes him look
like he's dying he looks like a smurf
they're trying to argue that it was like
oh but people looked on different
devices and that's why it looked that
way wow i took i i did the experiment
myself
i took joe rogan's video on the same
monitor same computer screen and i and i
played the video i screen grabbed it and
then i took the cnn clip and i screen
grabbed it you can clearly tell they're
different by the way i put them into a
graphic uh uh uh illustrator program
vectorize the images and then analyze
the color palettes to break it down whoa
and you can see it is manipulated he
literally in the top photo he looks like
one of those guys in the artsy hipster
part of the city that dresses as a
statue and like stands around for money
that is not how a normal human looks
without editing he looks like oj like
trying to do his own video but like he's
got the camera in the wrong yeah
but but this is just the point
when all of these mainstream
personalities high-profile celebrities
and regular people are like you rock the
narrative doesn't make sense when the ap
is like there's no evidence and then you
look at it you're like yo i have eyes i
can see it i know who are you going to
believe uh uh your eyes yeah but one
thing i wanted to mention piggybacking
off of what you said a moment or to
respond to what you said a moment ago
about the fact that um
they
don't seem to understand that they harm
themselves and their message by going
after these people because they end up
promoting them i think the reality is an
infant throwing a temper tantrum or a
toddler throwing a temper tantrum isn't
all that concerned with the optics
yeah and if they got to the point where
they could be concerned with the optics
they wouldn't be throwing the tantrums
anymore if it's but if the tantrum's
working then why do you care you know
like it works it works exactly and
they've been spoiled for way too long
and people are starting to go okay no
like i have to go to work i have to do
my job i'm not listening to this
think about what we're watching right
cnn has a temper tantrum
joe rogan responds very calmly and and
positively and says i'm a fan of neil
young it's great music sorry if i made
you mad guys you know we'll do better
very adult very mature the temper
tantrum doesn't work imagine you're
watching to you go to an ice cream shop
and you see one kid screaming and
banging on the counter give me ice cream
yeah and then the other kid is like
mother if if i get an extra scoop of ice
cream i promise to do my chores when we
go home you're gonna be like oh that
kid's very well behaved and that kid's a
little little
you know what i mean that's what we're
seeing from the outside you're watching
cnn have this tantrum and you're just
like they've lost their back but the
reason why kids have perpetual the kids
who have the tantrums all the time have
the bad parents who respond to it right
so that's the lesson so as a mother you
know then you don't you walk away you
don't even gauge the kid the kids who
have the perpetual tumblr tantrums are
the ones with the mom who keeps
appeasing them so this is what's
happening you got it you're talking
about a bunch of toddlers and if you add
mothers if you've got kids if you've got
kids
and and you know they're complaining
that they want something you got to make
sure you get the paperwork drawn up that
the the eyes are dotted these are
crossed and you make them sign that
contract and you you litigate everything
and say don't cry don't cry wait do the
paperwork you want one scoop of ice
cream well i want the dishes done so
sign here all right initial there
initial there all right we have a
contract here's your ice cream and we'll
get the dishes done teach them a good
lesson about how corporate world works
yeah really the longer the image is up
the more astounding like like what what
kind of middle school shenanigans is
that like i don't like him so i'm going
to make him look like drax yeah
it's the most obnoxious let's make him
look ugly in the picture yeah he looks
ugly now dude i remember when i wat i i
when i first heard the story about how
they do they changed the color i didn't
see it from joe i didn't see from
anybody i was i was watching the cnn
video
claiming he took it says he took horse
dewormer right there from they're lying
and i watched the video and i was like
yo joe looks bad yeah and then i look
like i want that horse do you want my
stuff right right
yo
it's so insanely obvious what they're
doing i feel like you know we're all
popping out of the matrix and they're
like stop no don't exactly people just
start waking up to the insanity of the
alive i feel bad for regular people who
are still trapped in there yeah you know
and they think they think they think
they're right because you've been
trusted but how do they respond so so
let's say it's the case because trying
to look at this from the lens of
someone who still trusts cnn and maybe
i'm giving them too much credit here
with respect to critical thinking
abilities right yes but
if cnn
put this on air and they really didn't
edit it he just happens to look like
he's from a different species in it but
they didn't notice that and still want
to air with it that's almost just as bad
because at the end of the day you're
getting false information as a viewer so
i'm really curious how the people who
are die-hard fans of this network or who
are loyal to it would respond to
something like james could respond to
something like this
cnn told me that they are the most
trusted name
yeah they told me that too and that's
and to be honest it might be true and
it's a low bar it is very likely and
they told me about that apple remember
that this is an apple no i don't
remember that i didn't know remember
when donald trump was elected right yeah
they were like this is an apple it's
just an apple or whatever and it's like
we're not fake news like we showed you
an apple or something and told you it's
an apple oh they're building crap i do
remember when don lemon was like
now it may be preposterous but was the
plane swallowed by a black black hole i
know and then and then the lady on cnn
goes well you know even a small black
hole would smaller the whole universe
what i'm not kidding that actually
happened and i'm like yo first of all
there's no way a black hole swallowed
the airplane second of all a small black
hole would not swallow the entire
universe or else we wouldn't have the
universe like that or we wouldn't have
black holes just one of the other you
know this isn't that complicated
do you think the jet got swallowed
let me just i just i i kind of feel bad
right now because
we get more views than cnn does we're
punching down we're playing oh you're
right we're bullying cnn we need to help
them no we need to we should pull up the
lab is constructive we should bring cnn
on the show to help them
get the word out about their channel and
maybe maybe they'll get more subscribers
oh my gosh bring john cnn on yeah
the man himself sucker has no ties now
maybe he'll come on and
speak all for us look i did the
photoshop it was mike
he wants revenge on chris cuomo now for
costing him his job
chris did that photoshop he's been
messing with premiere a lot lately
whatever what if he came in like a big
stack of documents i was like here's
everything
yeah
this is all like furry fanfiction
they have the truth as like
when you write the news you you write it
and then you write the fake version and
archive the real story and then publish
the fake one and they're like well so
remember that one story about trump
here's the actual story we actually do
for reference yeah for reference well
it's because they want to know the
history
exact opposite you know
so i i thought about how crazy it is
with all the fake news think about how
it's going to impact history and people
are going to believe the lies forever
it's going to be 100 years they're going
to be like donald trump was colluding
with the russians that's right i know
and that was cnn dude remember cnn was
the first network in january 10 19
what year was it not 19
2017
uh january 10 2017 they ran the i think
they won an award for it i think they
won a pulitzer prize
about the dossier and the briefing that
jim clapper did with trump uh uh and
with jim comey to tell them about the
russian p tape right so this oh that's
right so this really launched the the p
tape the dossier buzzfeed also published
it that day but cnn was responsible for
really launching russiagate um and
legitimizing it saying that clapper and
comey had met with trump and alerted
them that they had compromise on donald
trump and so that's where that that's
where it started also this is this is
good karma yeah also middle school
behavior like i'm going to say is impede
on him like he's just
nonsense like complete disgusting
nonsense totally depraved how insane was
that
hold on do you remember the story from
the huffington post where it was like a
tape exists of trump somewhere doing
something in an elevator no where he was
we don't know and what he did is un un
you were unsure of but he did it but
journalists know what happened and
they're trying to find out what it's
like but again millions of americans
still believe that that happened yeah
they still believe that there's a tape
with donald trump at the moscow ritz
with prostitutes urinating in front of
him they're like yeah that tape that
he's there well i gotta go
hold on uh i gotta i gotta be honest i
honestly do believe that trump will have
done something like that in his life but
whether the actual tape of it and the
circumstances they've proposed well
that's outrageous right well
the reason it works is because donald
trump is a crazy guy yeah well no yeah
no and that's why people believe that's
why you got a day
right does he i don't know yeah doesn't
he have a golden toilet yeah trump tower
yeah i heard that says yeah so well i
want to say one thing you mentioned uh
history and it's true that there are
probably a lot of things in our history
books that were just part of media
propaganda and we believe them today
however i will say this the new york
times tried as hard as they could to
cover up the whole little more and that
still came out the new york times also
very much under reported on the
holocaust that still came out so i think
it doesn't always happen it doesn't
always happen but i really genuinely
believe that when we need it the truth
does come out but but but sheamus
think about what you just said then
think about the new york times lying to
get us into the middle east
they're still around
no i know they are doing all of those
things it's true and people are still
like i'm going to read the new york
times but that's also maybe you
shouldn't i agree with you but i think a
big part of that was because prior to
the internet your average person who was
aware of these lies because they found
them through research couldn't point
them out yeah and it was hard to find it
was hard to research because they were
the arbiters of morality and truth
exactly but now we are in a different
age and information has been been
decentralized thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time